so I was flying into burbank airport the
other day and i remembered to look out
the window on approach something i
really like because on the way into
burbank you can see the durban boundary
the place where the wilderness turns
into the urban grid on the way to
burbank you come over an industrial area
you can see industrial buildings and
warehouses and i was really gratified to
see that most of those buildings had
light or white roofs and that's really
great because when you have a
light-colored roof or a white one it's
more reflective it means that it takes
less energy to cool those buildings
which is good for something called an
urban heat island effect it means
there's less heat getting kicked out
into the atmosphere around the city good
for climate change and it also means
that there's less carbon spent on
cooling off the buildings everybody wins
but the problem with that is that local
governments have to make the people who
own those buildings change the colors of
the rooftops so as I was flying in about
to come in for landing I started to try
to think well will there be a thing that
a government could do without having to
force anybody to change what they were
doing to change what's called planetary
albedo to raise the reflectivity of the
surface of a city in this case or maybe
even entire country so that you could
fight climate change and then it hit me
the blackest thing that I could see on
the way in were the roads these little
narrow ribbons of asphalt so I thought
well you have to be able to color those
white and then the government could do
that without having to give anybody
orders it's something that they're
supposed to be in charge of you could
raise planetary albedo and you could
save the planet I figured there were
plenty of area to do that with I thought
no back in the envelope there's like
what a million miles of road figure it's
an average of twenty feet and you do
that math and you get some like 4,000
square miles blacktop you could change
the white I've saved the planet I'm a
hero of course it turns out to be a lot
more complicated than that I called the
Federal Highway Administration to find
out how much road there actually was in
the United States and it's actually more
like four million miles but only 2.7
million Mozilla is paved and not all of
that is paved with asphalt some of it is
Portland cement and some of it is a mix
some of its concrete with asphalt
patches so that's more gray and someone
was even color they know how to make
this stuff any color they want to some
of its brown in front of the way
for example which is in the worst part
of it the worst part is they don't
actually know how wide these things are
you can't do the calculation of area
because federal highway administration
only calculates based on the number of
lanes so they can tell you how many what
the percentages of like four lane vs
tulane versus one lane and even the
little tiny fraction of a percentage of
20 lane when you get up to something
like a toll plaza okay I can't do that
math luckily someone else did I found
researcher named Hashem akbari he used
to work at Lawrence Berkeley Lab now
he's at Concordia University in Canada
and he's actually done some in this math
because he's interested in urban heat
Islands he says that the total albedo of
all of the paved surfaces in the u.s. is
0.1 the unit doesn't really matter here
the point is reflectivity and you'd like
to raise that because you're losing the
ice caps that usually do that work he
says with existing technology you could
put it at about 1.25 now Hashem did some
of the math figuring out how much
payment there was how big cities were he
figured that you could actually take
about thirty five percent of every urban
area and change that albedo raised at
that point 25 it ends up being 27,000
square miles if you change the albedo
just the amount that he was talking
about you get a reduction of 8 billion
tons of carbon that's the equivalent to
me that's worth it plus I figure think
how pretty that ride is going to be in
on approach from an airport when the
roads are all different colors